hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play inculcation
insulation in in in in coal in collation
eesh
I don't know anyway so this is another
horror flash game that you guys
recommended and it's actually extremely
highly reviewed so I'm actually pretty
excited I've never heard about it before
he was released a while ago I have no
idea how I got here oh okay it's this a
bunch of hand-drawn maps keying a gun
there are a few clips of ammo I have a
gun I can actually defend myself in this
game the window has been bricked up
doors locked
use key on door haha simple hi wow I
shot it whatever the hell that was
wasn't expecting something to jump out
right then in there what I found a holes
pipe what I've seem to be moving
exceptionally quickly there's a little
two and a nine down there is that
important at all mister it's really dark
outside all I can see is the sky see
some syringe there you took some
medicine those in those a needle you
just jammed it in your arm but you think
you are Simon geez stepping so weird no
water well let's see if I can hook a
hose pipe OOP nope okay apparently I
have to immediately start murdering
anyone I see okay there's a hole near
the handle always wipe can't use that
with door okay downstairs aha hold like
the host pipe doesn't work for anything
I don't know the combination well screw
you too yeah but get out of here Kelly I
lost your key when I cleaned the
fireplace sorry I'll look for it when I
get back okay boxes are filled with junk
I'm a feat of piece of string damn it no
damn it
all right fine I found string and
someone lost the key in the fireplace
somehow
Haho type oh that's right I'm gonna use
this hose pipe on something and it's not
gonna make any sense
not that I've used it on anything that
already in the head let's see found some
superglue for the key your drain Chios
No okay
and haha ah just see syringes lying
around in this house that I have no idea
how I got in here perfectly normal
empty mug in a deodorant can like scraps
of paper
nothing interesting apparently says it's
full of stuff but I wonder if there's
anything interesting
what well look open the drawer if you
want to see if there's anything
interesting whatever I'm outta here
it was at it I don't know the
combination that this door is not locked
oh hey oh you dick Oh
jab myself with t x-15
can't say that this is horrifyingly
scary this game I mean those monsters
are pretty piss-poor Lee John no offense
to the maker the game I need something
to capture haha why do I need this
string but why do I need this I did I
turned on the gas i turned the oven on I
don't know what your problem is
okay why oh there we go oh why look at a
huff it I seem to be taking drugs from
everywhere in here why don't I just
snort that down okay it's a good fit
why did I know that I needed that
there's someone moving around up there
oh ah blocked with this key oh okay
probably the key to one of the doors up
here kliklak mmm oh I thought something
was gonna jump out at me nothing found a
lighter boom oh no I don't want to kill
myself if I was in his house
okay anything else just found that
lighter those it really put the bag in
the hole Oh
put the lighter the hole ah when did it
start snowing in here why is it snowing
in here what doesn't make any sense at
all or is that dust just going by the
window oh that's very cool effect yes
plastic bag plastic bag plastic bag
plastic bag no yes no yes no yes all
right let's look here
lousy bag why do I need you what's going
on oh hello no I don't need to do that
it's a filthy coat yeah yeah you're a
filthy coat warning I seem to have
skipped a few steps here I'm not exactly
sure why or where or when or in what way
I would ever need this come on you you
pop that drawer open up that syringe TV
lab no nothing none of it none of it
none of it no nothing nothing at all
whoa whoa whoa let me go back to like
yeah the original room whoa well okay
put away okay that door is locked but I
don't know where the key is to that door
this has nothing in it there's two and a
nine-hole drive up there well I mean
whatever you order I don't even
I'm joke confused like it rushed me
through the first few parts with no
explanation of what I was doing I was
just doing it and then all of a sudden
here it stops
maybe it's obvious maybe I am an idiot
actually I'm pretty sure in the over 700
videos I've done I've already
established said I'm kind of an idiot
okay lock from a latch to the other side
there's a hole near the handle I had
something to use on that hole handle I
could do that I just gotta find it I
just gotta find it I just have to fly it
ah the of it off don't need oh they tell
you it was amazing if you bought the
pads cupboard lines bricks water
temperature don't you take these this on
anything turn on the gas blow myself up
no okay well I am like there's gotta be
some here there's gotta be something
that I'm missing that's exceptionally
obvious because most of the things wait
a minute that TV mark wouldn't cut now
can't use that on that don't need a
syringe
maybe if I overdose on drugs I can get
out of this nightmare by dying
and then come on there's gotta be
there's gotta be something going on here
lost the key when the fire please oh ah
aha yes that's why knee boom what
okay all right whatever whatever you
know what in all of what stop that
okay that's the first really creepy
thing that's ever happened in this game
excuse me okay manikin large pin haha
this mannequin freaks me out it looks
like one of those creatures I don't even
know what those creatures were oh hello
oh I could brute force my way through
this but I out take forever Oh God oh no
the combinations are endless actually is
five times four times three two teams of
one huh
this huh yeah okay I'm not gonna okay so
there's some sort of really dark out
there but I can just make out a wall
well that's handy let's go back
oh come on I thought I thought for
shizzle it was gonna work it like that
well okay I have a large pin now but
what do I do with it
stab this freaking mannequin and geez
okay ah oh no no oh no oh god no okay
I'm never gonna get that attornies stop
maybe I can get the drawer open I don't
know none of this seems to make sense
why give me a tiny itty-bitty bobby pin
nothing to use it on whoops oh sorry
about that
I'm so confused
I don't think there's anything I got the
key out of here so I doubt there'd be
anything left in there bobby pin on the
door yeah
what okay in a completely illogical
fashion what why would I need a bobby
pin ah Dennis crushed
you
ah [ __ ] you Jesus I thought a coat
hanger screw you man why the hell did
that work I'm gonna go down there and
take some drugs before I go in there
uh-huh uh-huh you sure yeah okay all
right there we go oh it's a bathroom
jeez ah why is it so quiet why is it so
quiet it was it I don't know I didn't
want to put my hand in there in the
first place okay can I get out
can I go okay wait what what do you say
wait sets over here there's a lock in
some switches key fits but it won't turn
I don't know it's really quiet now
things got dirtier there just me or did
things get dirtier why are things
dirtier okay what's going on okay one
six two where's the bathroom there it is
two nine two six nine is player number
okay nothing else in there there had to
be oh come on I don't know I don't know
the combination to the lockbox I don't I
don't know there's guy I don't know
I don't know how am I supposed to know
this okay there had to be some clue that
something gave me a while ago I don't
know okay if it's one six
I don't know I don't know how am I
supposed to know this how's anybody
supposed to know
this I'm just gonna brute force my way
through this highly doubt that that
would be the design Oh God not that geez
I am do not have time to answer the
phone right now I'm being creeped out
all right so nothing so far just quiet
okay all right okay all right all right
he was I'm okay I'm fine
okay so if I think what was that
if I think logically about this there
has to be some clue probably in this
area no nothing nothing there just a 1
in a 6 in there the two and the 9 in
there really dirty room in here and
nothing nothing there's not a thing here
there's nothing here I there's no okay
I'm just gonna I'm gonna brute force my
way through this okay so that didn't do
it okay let's just go through all the
permutations I might cut some stuff out
here so if this gets exceptionally
boring but I don't know I have any other
way so here we go I just hear something
like creep around I don't know I don't
know I swear I hear something something
is something is happening oh no that's
not right is this I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know there's no way I'm gonna get all
this I'm too much of an idiot to get any
of this I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know
okay
all right there's got to be something
that is a clue somewhere here and the
app the awkwardness of the silence is
falling so should be fine I just
I'm awfully confused more than anything
like this whole game I've been just
confused I don't know why anything is
working the way it is it just seems to
be happening I'm going back in every
single room why why in the world does
any of this work seriously why why does
this work all right you know what I'm
gonna jump ahead into the future to see
what happens when I actually solve this
puzzle so be right back
what up oh ok I found something here I
don't know what hand I got the pin I
need to guide the pin through the lock
I shouldn't press the pin what ok
alright wait hang on well what the pin
doesn't move how am i how am I not it
the pin doesn't move the pin doesn't
move yeah use your arrows no how did I
but what maybe I gotta move the cursor
uh-oh oh there we go yeah that would
have been helpful before but for some
reason the thing popping out of the
closet maybe think that there was
nothing in there ok so up up down up
down I thought I did that one whatever
ok up up down up down I thought I coulda
sworn I did that one at one point ok
yeah I found it Oh - oh I know what
that's for I know exactly what that's
for ah
hahaha who you OOP
aha one so that means six nine one is
the combination I know it
six not what oh there we go
found a key from door key oh shut up are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] they jump
are you err I thought I could sworn oh I
could've sworn
haha I could have sworn that sent me to
the beginning and I would have been so
unbelievably pissed you wouldn't even oh
god you don't even know okay so what
happened out here where am I
hmm no thank you
look mmm that feels good man oh I found
a large sheet now I can pretend to be a
ghost that's good no no screw you I know
what that leads to why are there veins
in the walls that is bad
I've seen this before ah oh this is nice
oh okay yeah it's nice hmm that's nice
I didn't it didn't creep me out no it's
fine it was nice okay I found two sheets
whoa Oh aha oh no I need to climb out of
there
Oh mommy this is those real thumbs
relatively nice okay well uh huh got it
got ha it got dirty again why is
everything so dirty
I'm so confused now what is happening
hey I'll bet the gate doesn't move part
on the left looks like an entrance oh
Jesus I didn't even know I went in I
just was clicking trying to kill him and
it just sent me in okay I don't know
look it drink it's available for
purchase Jayma have no money broke [ __ ]
alright sugar sugar money whoa what did
I just get what did I get a stomach why
I'm just clicking I'm not intending to
automatically click on these things it's
just the game is set up that way it's
like I don't know nothing i okay so I
have what is wrong with this character I
mean okay if he's if you're thrown into
some diabolical nightmare I guess yeah
you do pretty much anything but why why
why
give me a corridor give me a damn
quarter I'm thirsty I have a thirst and
the only way can we quench
give me a quart mom I sob I give a
corner okay they're quarter out down
here okay so the door is locked
electronically here's uh is a box there
nope
well maybe I could use this as a coin
now it accept coins okay
all right so get away I don't know I
don't know what to do
please let a little of them okay maybe
there's a way I could go back nope
that's once I'm here I'm here
literally nothing I could do well what
the hell I don't know this whole game is
just confusing me I mean as I addressed
in the beginning I am a giant idiot I am
but this what is going on I didn't
expect this game to be this long either
hello anybody here there's nothing here
can't do anything there's no coins
nothing to get there's nowhere to go
little there's nowhere to go there is
nothing there is nothing
okay that's my fault that's me that is
on me because I assumed that when it
said flat - I thought that was like a
room inside there K whatever ha Boston
doing a screen recorder that's why that
happened
okay it is a key to the room I did not
know that this key could also open there
was a hole here it's gone now haha
this is cry of fear Hey look oh good I
needed that drug is that what's going on
what is what am I looking at all of this
is British this is this is all British
look at these plugs look at these what
is that it's awfully not obviously not
merican jeez
what a weird ooh I can get a coin yay
money found a lever of some kind okay
okay 300 the number 300 is highlighted
in blue okay needs a fixture okay I
don't have the gambling fixture okay for
some reason 300 is important
was that ah
no put it back put it back put it back
put it back
what is that 300 okay 300 what oh I know
what I need to do wait what is that okay
hey I guess I got an idea here it's
crazy
nope nope good there no put that back
okay
ah ah those Mart hi those Mart
but this ha ha ha 50p up BAM
yeah oh yeah are you all right yeah so
smart ha yeah ha ha bow bill Oh what
okay huh see ah bollocks
Sam turn to British already need to
replace the fuse for putting the case
back on so where would I find a fuse
Oh screw you
ah
ha ha ha ha what what well hey no I need
to buy hang on 1.5 kilograms oh yeah
wait no no wait well was the number the
number was something what was the number
one point two five one point two ah math
problem where my incredible intelligence
is go and say why is there a bus here by
the way I did not notice that just now
until I said wait a minute there's a bus
here on the second floor of this
apartment complex I did not think about
that okay so now huh huh put flour bub
yeah
without their poop up Clegg it out at
300 flubber dish oh yeah wait two
seventy eighty ninety three other second
three hundred do a 290 300 yeah three
hundred that's three hundred would that
do well come on now
come on right now he'll have to be
unlike the exact pistol or something oh
it's skipping over that pic so I can see
it okay there we go right out 300 don't
know what that means but here we go ah
oh there's the bus
what I don't Oh where'd you go from stop
tripping blood give me that
shut up Barry oh look it's a
double-decker was it what did I just
click on well the hell did I just click
on what did I just click on where am I
what why does nothing in this game
expire self when two beasts collide the
gateway to hell can be reached I don't
know get it off there I screw I'm going
back how did I get what I thought the
back of the eye
ling-ling ling-ling ling-ling
Babli living you junk smart oh good
fat o'clock hand I don't know was that I
thought it looked like a clown or
something
I'm awfully lucky that I managed to get
that on the first try ah okay so the
blue is 300 I didn't see any red numbers
three two there's rare numbers maybe I
don't know I - damn Oh clown lady that
was a hole here it's gone now seems to
be a hole still here so I can just kind
of poured it into here oh wait no I see
yellow 240 I see it aha trick me
yellow is 240 is he - 70 - Nicky 50 40
OOP okay red is who knows and there's a
green one on the wall that I can't seem
to get off lift
huh power seems to be down
oh wait maybe maybe if I go back outside
this and clink long damn oh no oh I
don't see how cutting the power would
have helped it all you're right you're
right on the Nidhi
okay so they're like number hang on let
me just carefully go through maybe
there's numbers written somewhere
no further use of vending machines man I
tell you this game is involved a lot
longer than I thought it was gonna be
lot longer okay 90 green grid I think
that's it not yeah 90 highlighted in
green I see was there something here ah
okay that's the only where else could
there be a number if I going back in the
bus okay nothing there nothing there
okay what's here when two bees collide
tachi Deb I moved I could collide no two
beasts secured to the wall well get it
off the wall what is all this
see spear and shield they're all
attached securely but I'm pretty strong
I could probably I could probably get
off there
let's go walrus skull small metal
ornament I don't I don't know once again
I'm stuck I don't know I don't know
where I'm going I need to get that off
the wall somehow that's got to be the
number-one priority but I don't know how
to do that aha 120 I don't know who's
gonna help because I don't have any way
it was already out 120 whoops okay so
that's their that's their that's her but
the other ones either 60 or some okay so
that's there how do I get the green one
off the wall how do i how do I get it
off the wall I have bolt cutters but
nothing to cut or nothing to do with it
lab has no bulb I mannequins still
they're being weird how do I get it off
the wall it's there I see it I want it I
want it I want it so badly I want it so
badly god I want it how do I get it how
do I get it how do I god I heard I got
it oh oh my god I
Cato Qaeda bhaji Oh what potato no yeah
all right uh in the advent of speeding
things up here I'm gonna jump we head
another bit cuz this been going on way
longer than I thought going and that's
not a bad thing but I just mean I don't
wanna take up too much um so I'll be
right back oh ha ha I can move these ah
ok ah I don't know what kind of be said
is that y'all come at me bro oh I'm
gonna get you oh my body is ready oh
that wasn't much of a gate to hell
really oh the colliding beast right ok
what was it green when the green wasn't
was anyone was yeah 90 no 90 okay green
one is 90 90 yeah wait a minute that
doesn't look good doesn't wait didn't
that message say there was a hole here
it's gone now isn't this a bad thing
that I just did
no sugar baby
oh sure divers are the only I need okay
I'm done
Oh No I am the monster okay only one way
to go down ah ha ha ha
you shouldn't have said you're heavy oh
wait no oh go come a little closer buddy
Oh due to new closer huh what dad Oh
words at high divers one out
aha tug on that Oh give me that oh yeah
oh wow
yeah yeah you [ __ ] huh I just had to
pick the one that was not not the
correct one what
what what what what was that me was that
who shot what huh how are you feeling
now leg [ __ ] understandably are you
alright to proceed with the interview
yeah when you woke up from the amnesty
net amnestics M nee sticks how did you
feel I fell fine no headache nothing
just confused
perfect what was your initial reaction
to seeing another human being
I was scared they didn't seem human
aside from having the same body
structure I was under the distinct
impression they wanted to harm me
their appearance alone made me feel like
I had to defend myself
as you know t x-15 is designed to make
the subjects see other humans as alien
and threatening well it works it's also
engineered to remove individuality from
the subject from them so the subject
feels no guilt in killing them they had
no distinguishable features not even
fair shows it was creepy he made it out
of the house so would you agree that
your intelligence was that normal
capacity I'd say so yeah sounds like
we're ready to take T x-15 to the
military I'm not so sure there were some
weird side effects such as I saw some
weird shirt things who weren't even
possible hallucinations I suppose T x-15
uses hallucinogens to distort the
appearance of humans we need to
fine-tune them I take it okay so hey as
long as I get my money I don't care of
course thank you for taking the drug
trial hahaha
really that's your explanation for all
of it
oh man that was really good I mean
honestly that was really really good I
got F screwed you you know what you take
your ass and shove it off you're a
hayride either see see what I do there
okay so anyway thank you all so much for
joining me I'm glad I'm glad that was
picked up everyone in the beginning you
know it seemed like oh this isn't so bad
you know but then it kind of picked up a
lot that cried baby that hole there I'm
freaky I wouldn't I think I've ever
heard anyway that was really really good
I really really I really liked that I
can see why it's highly reviewed in the
beginning I was unsure but now I'm
pretty sure I mean a lot of it kind of
I'm a little sick so sorry a lot of it
felt like you know I I didn't know
exactly where I was being led and you
know there was some common sensing that
I missed but all in all I felt like some
things in there were a bit you know
questionable overall in terms of you
know level design in leading the
character to the correct progression but
as far as some other flash games I
played perfectly acceptable I got
through it and perfectly reasonable time
so thank you all so much for joining me
hope you enjoyed it click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
Oh mother I'm bad
yeah okay oh god I cannot lose this now
I was gonna win